how about Ronnie infarcted in Vegas by
the way did you know he was checking out
houses while he was out oh I'm just
saying in a year you're retiring the
plan is we're gonna move out this time
he's got a job lined up all right I'm
gonna lay on my [ __ ] ass by the pool
dude you don't even have a hobby what
the [ __ ] is going to worry about don't
worry what's your high I'll be fine can
I tell you something I was thinking
about you what are you thinking about
look let's say I do stay
he gave up your [ __ ] mojo which was
being on the radio with us okay it's
time dude no more acting parts no more
celebrity friends morons Adam Sandler
will not call you when you're Ronnie who
retires her Vegas was hogging him up
here he loves Ronnie okay so this one I
should get Donny the limo driver oh
that's good hey Ron what are you doing
today I'm wandering the desert I'll be
cleaning up tiger shift for Siegfried
and Roy that would be Ronny the Elvis
impersonator right I know he's gonna
start like ubering just to kill time and
stuff yeah go back to driving would rate
me on a scale of one to five Ronnie the
angry dude would be like what did I do
I'll join the Blue Man Group I'll be the
only one with liver spots and you should
hear me after like a guest leaves like
you know oh oh well Paul McCartney goes
yeah he's a great guy man I was talking
to Paul out in the hall and I was
talking to his people and all this [ __ ]
there's gotta be any people okay you
don't know anything no you don't know
anything sour grapes over there why you
got to be sour grace I hope you have the
greatest life ever but I'm just trying
to [ __ ] tell you once you leave the
door shut can't be I got to get someone
else like the Mafia there's no coming
back help you find somebody if you want
he's gonna be that grouchy old man that
the kids harass yeah don't you know
rosebud
get off my lawn please my Christmas
dragon you would think after all these
years I've been with you you'll be
[ __ ] happy for me I'm happy for you
kill my [ __ ] deal I'm just saying I
used to hang out with the blinds closed
and what happened to the animal hospital
you're opening that already what do you
mean you said Shirley said she has a job
I'm gonna run a diff lined up right
Jesus don't go there and open up a
hospital right oh well that's what we
all told you thought this out no I never
told you that no we we told his room
told you who [ __ ] yourself okay Shirley
go outside yes for your [ __ ] to say
he did the buzz no he didn't but I do
have a back-up plan
hello cameo this is actually he can send
the $50 to PayPal dude I was talking to
my doctor too and he was telling me
about what happens to your brain once
you retire and like honey you don't have
that stimulation right you imagine Ronny
I got to mention a nursing home watch
it's gonna be interesting you're gonna
wanna know about it you don't know what
I'll know you wanna know nothing I only
know nothing no you won't know nothing
we don't know anything they'll have a
long beard long finger sounds like you
got a good plan Rhys got a good plan
[Music]
Doni the limo drivers a hit on Ronnie
John a rot in the sand in the dead
panty slots and bingo every [ __ ] day
I know somebody who made $300 on the
penny slot
Ronnie's nurse stole his money why am I
having a nurse now
Ronnie threw out all his shoes with
laces and got velcro shoes time for
Ronnie sponge bath
Ronnie shower has a handrail I love you
power
I think I'm recognizing I don't want to
see you make a mistake my contract ends
as of next December right that's the day
you're done right if you wanted me to
stay a couple of months to Train
somebody or some train yeah what to pick
me up who trained you so you've done as
December was whatever December next year
yeah Jason would speak but he's great
they're currently laughing
uncontrollably he just wants to know how
long it takes to train someone to stand
in front of a drawer all the [ __ ]
sour bastards back there that's right
dude look I believe that he has some
sense and he'll revoke this maybe sleep
on it tonight and come back don't you
wanted yet you want a night to sleep I
don't want a night to sleep on it Ronnie
don't be impetuous he doesn't know what
that means you can't be something me to
know what I mean don't even ask the
spell okay